Okay, welcome to the DDPS seminar everyone.
Before we introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and logistics. First
of all, please mute yourself during the talk.
But if you have questions, you can unmute
and ask questions, or use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in q&a session at the end. Second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to external
audiences. Therefore, no classified discussion
is allowed. So please watch out. Finally, the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel. That's about it. Now let me briefly
introduce our speaker today. It is an honor
to host Professor Yana chan in mathematics
department at University of Massachusetts
Dartmouth. Yanni received his PhD in mathematics
from School of Mathematics University of Minnesota
in 2007. He then worked as a postdoctoral
researcher at Brown University before joining
the department of mathematics at the University
of Massachusetts that that month in August 2010,
where he currently serve as a full professor, Dr.
Chen's research has been supported by the NSF,
AF post SR and onr via University of Massachusetts
Dartmouth must program. His research interests are
in numerical analysis and scientific computing, in
particular finite element methods. We use spaces
methods and other first algorithms, uncertainty
quantification, design and analysis for machine
learning algorithms. He has graduated five
doctoral students and initiated the University
of Massachusetts that mathlete my dad math is
our complete program here on NSF grant to provide
students in need financial, social and curricular
support today, and I will talk about GPT pin
and TGP T pin generative pre trained physics
informed neural network toward non intrusive,
meta learning of parametric PDS. Please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk now let me ask a couple
of questions to Jana, just to get to know you
better and make this seminar somewhat informal.
So first question, here we go. Obviously, you're
passionate about scientific machine learning,
when and how did you get into this
field and study to do research on them?
Thank you, first of all, for that long bio
and her long title. Thank you for for reciting
appreciate it. So I've been working on reduce
space is a method which is by itself a machine
learning algorithm. So I sort of know the, the
machine learning field a bit even without doing,
you know, explicitly the maybe the more modern
significant machine learning projects. So it
has been in my mind, in my mind to work on ICS
I saw some connections to work on, you know,
the neural network specific stuff for a few
years and, and, and, and I started working on
it together with a student Sean Connery about
two years ago, two lessons three years ago.
So I'm a newcomer here. I'm looking forward
to learning from you know, all the experts.
Okay, great. Second question is, you're
passionate about teaching and mentoring students,
right? So if you can, you know, share some thought
about how, why and why why you enjoy, you know,
mentoring students and, you know, teaching them
and, etc, that if they're awesome, as a professor
I think part of it is maybe self centered. To
be honest. I went out when I get excited about
the stuff that I teach. So when I when I when I
want to be able to enunciate what what what I saw
this concept is about I got to my mix it myself.
I think, you know, Eric, there was point to that,
that side of that kind of excitement is
some are contagious to students. Students
get excited too. And, and, and, you know,
of course, there's more traditional stuff,
you know, we put in the work and you see
progress from students. You most of the
times is probably a bit hard and challenging.
Like just like research, you have setbacks,
but you know, once a while and once in once
a while You'll see a great progress that make
it all the whole effort worthwhile. So that I
think that's you're seeing that growth sea level
and the graduate level. That's, that's what it is
profession is about, and I truly enjoyed doing it.
Sounds wonderful. All right, the stage is yours.
All right. Thank you so much, also for inviting
me to the seminar. Thank you for your work in
doing this DDPS seminar and, and giving me
the opportunity to talk to your audience,
I certainly treasure this opportunity. I today I
was reflecting on the lock that I had last year
last room meeting wonderful Google member, Tony
Chung, I'm not sure I don't see the audience. I'm
not sure he's he's here, but I appreciate talking
to him last year at Morgan State is here. So as
a young song, alright, as it yawns aren't just
announced. So I'm going to talk to you about
GPD PN and the TT PDP in today. And I have the you
know, the meters as the title is somewhat somewhat
of a gimmick, but I think it's literally true,
you hopefully you get you will be convinced. So,
this is a joint award the most I will spend
the most of time talking about the GDP,
which is a linear reduction method in pins
fashion. So, that says the linear part,
I spent a few slides towards the end to talk about
the extension to the nonlinear part. And the first
part is joint work with Shang Kui a fantastic
undergrad student with going into a graduate
program soon and as a second part has was just
submitted a few weeks ago with our with Yachty
and our key on our ion and agenda issue Alright,
so, here is what I would I was hoping to be your
take home message of the seminar today and and and
the DVD pin to pin is what RVM is to AV E M. So,
we have the finite element method we solving you
know equations and in the multi query setting,
that is the wrong people, we all care about the
you know, one particular Master is a call to
reduce bases method. And in the you know, today's
award, we use a neural network for things either
with the family weaving fashion, let's say you
know, the pin is basically also a PD servo and GDP
is basically a a extension of our VM to the to the
to the pins to a different machine learning field.
So, this little bit of diagram is is the overall
message. His outline, I will give you a brief
intro of the so called P Mo's projection based
model order reduction. And then I spent a slide on
pins and then talk about you know, how, how we go
from pin to, to TV DVD pin. And I'm gonna show you
some results for the CBD pin. And finally, again
from the linear to nonlinear extension. So the
mouse requires setting I'm pretty sure you know,
this community is quite familiar with. So here we
have simulations or dynamic simulation, or maybe
you know, the radar signature type of simulation,
we need to change things, maybe the shape of the
car, right or the flow field or angle material of
the fighter jet or those things and you want
to optimize the aerodynamic performance of
the vehicle or the radar signature to minimize
that of your of your object. By tweaking your
input the shape on all those that were just
mentioned, or privacy, you know, you want to
perform sensitivity analysis, you saw all these
situation, you need to solve parametrical system
over and over. So you need to the former sort of
has to be performed many, many many times. And,
and we cannot really afford to, you know, always
use a flawed or model for those forward solve. So
this is a quick slide on the team with, you know,
some references and here what I'm showing you is a
is a electromagnetic problem and and what you want
is called discretize the domain and you see the,
you know, a lot of triangles on the on the
surface, and there's basically two there's
a large number of degrees of freedom to show
those degrees of freedom And and and under the
projection based model order reduction strives to
accelerate the simulation. So, in particular for
the for the RBM is the linear reduction creates
a particular answers. So why does is that it
explores the parameter parameter domain and find
a few representative parameter values. And then
you you use your favorite forward order model
for the model to solve for the solution at those
locations. So, those are the other solutions that
I use, I'm given here the u one, u two u three and
for the for the other parameter values, you try
to come up with a surrogate, so, here is a linear
combination we have your you know, pre selected
a pre computed solutions and the past exam is of
course, how do you find those and, and dimensions
and pre computed solutions. And on top of that,
given those How do you calculate the coefficients
C one C two c three I got to shed some light on
those. So, this this you give me a new I calculate
this the CS C one C two c n and coding that Prime
Minister code map. So, the for the for the P
more what I mean, certainly as a Master's how
you calculate this see maybe by interpolation
or, you know, a learning, but the traditional
PMO is based on solving the PDE in the in the
reduced setting. So, here's what I'm trying to
emphasize in bed physics. So we have, we have an
equation our simple reaction diffusion equation,
I'm taking mu as as as the two parameters. And the
weak solution for the PDE is you know, we look for
solution in the h1 zero space, we saw the, you
know, the week formulation. And finite element
is is describing is discretizing the space each
one zero by a financial space VH perhaps a linear
piecewise polynomial, for example. And they used
to discretize the lien by linear form a pie ah,
basically numerical differentiation in numerical
integration. And by doing that you're looking
you're you're solving, you know, a dessert is
formulation. In another space in a space of VH,
you're going from h one, zero to v h. So that
reduced basis, I'm using very loosely the term
structure preserving the reservation is one
step toward along this line. So it looks for
a another space, which I'm calling wn WM, who is
a supersaver, subsidiaries of VH. Other than that,
and then of course it has function is in that is
conforming medicine in the same space. Other than
there's no change, you saw the same formulation,
bye bye. That's what I loosely manned by structure
preserving, there's no you know, I'm not talking
about physical structure preserved. So that's,
that's, you know, the traditional finite element,
the reduced basis method. And there's a bit of
theory behind all that the key concept of
the Kolmogorov and weeds. So essentially,
what it does, it either measures to what
extent you know, your, your, your manifold,
your solution manifold yield, you by going
through all the different meal value in your
parameter domain, how's that solution manifold
can be approximated by a n dimensional space x n,
you take the distance and then you you,
you find the best possible paths in theory.
And at this distance, of course, is defined
in this way. And for, for for many problems,
especially, it's probably with a bit
diffusion. So this angle is decay fast,
exponentially fast. So that would allow us to come
up with a space W N that that would approximate
the original fine atmosphere is really well and
that's, you know, you give it hope that you can
find a really good surrogate. So the key question
of how do you construct this space W M, all right.
There's uh, you know, why did he use method called
pod? The pod type approaches what it does is,
you sample your meal domain, I sample Let's say
you know a lot, and then you do your, you know,
your, your SVD. And you basically say you truncate
down the key what is truncate down, you, you know,
you maybe you have 10,000, solutions, snapshots
and you truncate, you take, you know, the first
10, right, for example, so, you ended up using a
lot more than that, you ended up acquiring the,
for the model a lot more times than the one your
thing is, and so that 10 Sounds is much larger
than 10. That's what I'm trying to say here. So,
that's, that's a, perhaps a top down approach,
you go, you know, you sum a lot and then you cut
down and RB is, is, is advocating for a something
called greedy algorithm. So what it does is,
is, is a bot a nap. So we go from empty sad to
the resources space, which I will describe more
later in the TPP. Inserting, the end result is,
if you only need 10 dimension space, in the end,
you only by the time you construct your space,
you only have carried out 10 times of your folder
model. So that's a big difference. So that's the
message that I'm trying to emphasize here, the
amount of form data for the model data is going
from big to small by going from pod to RB. And
going back to the key part of you know, the b2c
map for me to see mu certainly have been other
approaches. So the new network type approaches,
and I'm really seeing just a few of them. And that
is by far not a company that used and started from
around 2018 ish, by habeas group or the pod and
n. And there was, this is a landmark paper by
Karbach and co authors proposing the auto encoder
in this reduction setting. And the, you know,
the overall message here is that once you train
the map for me to see mu for you give me a new mu,
I simply evaluate the map, the train map, so
map recovery via direct evaluation of an event
during evaluation and drug evaluation. And, and
I want to point out there is a nice theoretical
paper here. And what what they essentially
proved is that, for problem where RBM works,
basically those are a low rank structure that
exist a dnn that will, that can approximate this
solution map to your accuracy. And furthermore,
they proved as the upper bound of the size of
the dnn is essentially the cubic of the of the
intrigues intrinsic dimension as an ice walk
there. So I'm trying to put these muscles in a in
a in a in a Catalog Catalog exam, the pod while I
put it here, meaning meaning that you know, you
need more, you need more data. So the horizontal
axis is amount of data, what God says is the
amount of physics the reducing water is based
on the PDE so is there as a physics in India,
the nm regression, you need data because you
train the map by the day but data so you train you
that's a data intensive approach in general. And,
and as a result, there's no physics in the way
you give me new I give you the CMU RBM is sort
of in the second quadrant, perhaps a more more
preferred one, you you need less form data, while
having more physics encoded. And speaking of, you
know, numerical solvers, there's a there's a since
2018 19, there's a family of Mossad called pin
physics inform neural network so what it does is,
is it has this complicated function right it's
a linear operation composed with a nonlinear
functions and keep keep doing that and, and, and,
and, and you basically use that as your solution
to a PDE. And what you what you do then is you
use the magic of auto differentiation and and you
calculate a loss. Appointed value appointed point
wise loss, the collocation setting and the the new
banana walkers and trains those waste tab Do the
BIOS P, or maybe there's something in the sigma
that nonlinear activation function, train all that
by minimizing this this, this loss, this loss,
this loss not only contains the PDE the residual
residual, the residual, but also the duration of
your solution with the boundary condition and the
initial condition. So, in a way it is satisfy PDE
and also the boundary needed conditions, you know,
your training on here, your MSE is small enough,
or maybe you cannot decrease it anymore. And
you take that stata as your as your you know,
as your as your network configuration. And that
network function is then your PD solution. Right?
So simple but powerful and popular idea. So, of
course, as somebody in the wrong community, right,
once, you know, I saw this, I was like, Okay,
what do we do? Well, you need to solve a parameter
given an equation, of course, to people in pain,
you could just add a mu here as the input, right.
So that's one way to do it. But the drawback is
you are introducing a larger network. And, and and
retraining takes more time or, or that, you know,
disadvantages. So if we just look at if we don't
do that approach, and we have this, you know,
every time you have a meal, you train your Seder,
the network configurations, and the challenges
of try to work with that is, is we observed,
there's a, you know, there's not really a low rank
structure within your Seder, we showed a graph in
the paper. And that's what I just mentioned.
So, so some some related attempts, and again,
is by far not a complete list as I'm listing a
few of them. So the first one is, basically to
play with these, those Satan's star. And, you
know, you you do regression interpolation type
of scenes in your parameter space and, and you
take the traditional matrilineal approaches I'm
calling PIM plus x. So the X is whatever approach
you do with your status star. And, and but again,
it's actually related with, you know, there is
no good law rug structure from what we observed.
The second is a tip Oh, nine and a half and oh,
so these are more pod based thinking. So you,
and it's data driven. And again, once you train
it, you basically just evaluate the map. And the
man I know is taking on a more transfer learning
approach. And again, the surrogate is fully data
driven, and more reasonable and is called P R.
and M by by by Chen, one has Haven and Jiang. And,
and they introduced basically to, you know, to not
do the data driven, but also to incorporate a bit
physics in that training. In a training of the
map. Again, once you have your train to the map,
you know, you give me a new meal is to evaluate
evaluate of the train map. So this is what I'm
summarizing here also method is sort of in the in
the fourth quadrant, is you need more data. And
the out the end result is a is a is a map that
you evaluate for a given meal, and a pie and
and put it in the third quadrant here takes a bit
less data. And so the question for me to ask was,
what about this second quadrant? Can we, in the
setting, can we do something with less data,
but more physics. And that's what I'm trying
to argue here. That's what lgpd pin belongs.
And now the design of the DVD been so what I'm
going back to, you know, where I started from
the reading space is muscle. So that's what
inspired this whole thing. And this is the
answers or the release basis. So you are taking a
linear combination of your pre computed and a well
chosen solution. And now, you know, the first step
is of course, if you use pin, you just replace the
solution by the pin. Right. And what it is,
is if you you know you take a look, it's just
a one layer zero bias network, you take linear
combination, u plus zero and n a is certainly
the way Because of this layer and I see I think
of it as a wait and slightly interesting one is
this this pin the perceive see the eye rise eyes
pin it for the whole nother walk this these eyes
pin is essentially a activation function, but it's
not, you know, the regular ones are very low or
that isn't it's not those you have to put it up
to put their customized activation function so
to speak. So that's what we did, we, you know,
we have this reduced network, so it's basically
only to something and one network and you gave
me an x t, I have you know, in one hidden layer,
right, while hidden layer, the hidden layer
has n networks, each neuron is full network,
and then I put a weight here and I combine
them to get my reduced solution. So, the,
the, the generative part is that you give me a new
mu, right so in parametric setting, you give me mu
A basically generate a this network this reduced
solution for you. That's, you know, one one point
to point out one thing to point out is that as a
meal comes in as the as the as the loss function,
you give a new meal, the meal designs, otherwise
the whole network is independent of meal,
right, it looks potentially confusing, but
whereas a meal comes in us through the loss,
the loss of the network, so give me new meals
that defines a loss for a particular loss
for the network. And then another word goes
ahead and a train those seeds those weights,
that's basically the simple idea. And and these
guys are pre trained, so pre trained pins pre
train and you put in their training takes time,
but once you train it you put it down as a as a
neuron as activation activation that evaluation
takes you know is quick so the next point is that
these guys are growing one by one just like as
greedy that I will see describing for fire for
for reduced phases. So we started by a 211 at a
walk and then it grows for two to 123 wide and
all the way to two n one I'm going to describe
the greedy algorithm later. So that sort of the
features either embeds physics because the loss
alright that you train the network by minimizing
decreasing the loss the loss has because it has
a residual and the boundary and each condition in
need. And in is small form data is again is a is
a ground up approach. It starts with with empties
and then goes 123 is not a top down approach.
And it has meta neurons by by by what we meant,
you know, just each activation is a four network
so it's a network network approach. And either
non intrusive, by which by which I meant is
you don't need the knowledge of of the pin.
So we have the example where we tested on Allen
calm we use a self adaptive pin, we don't need to
know what's going on inside those neurons in the
in the Wi Fi than they are there. And just like
you know other raw muscles eat accelerate the
underlying method here is x accelerated the pin
the margin of acceleration is two to three orders
of magnitude just again like you know what we see
for the traditional RVM type of result. And and
before showing the result I want to mention you
know, just a couple of things one is that the
success of this is largely based on the the
derivatives are linear and the pinhole pins in
is collocation is collocation in nature, right.
So he's more recent is more local. And, and those
things allow us to to pre compute. So just just
like you know, wrong approaches either offline
or online setting stages and here we pre compute
the quantities that that we need for online. So
that's important, important piece, and another one
to connect with with our VM which will allow me to
describe the greedy algorithms that I promise you
is this a post GRE Ira estimator? So that's a key
element for this for these basics. You need that
to explore your solution space to identify the
net just a sampling point. And that's, you know,
in RV for people who know, a finite element,
that's more or less straightforward because
basically the standard residual residual based
error estimation, your scale by, you know, your,
your stability constant. And, and, and. And if
we think about the neural data walk the pins,
the loss is based on the residual, so the MSE is
that I talked about. So we sort of have a, I have
a automatic choice there. So take the loss of
the reduce never walk, there's a residual based
indicator, right? So that's what I'm going to use.
So here's a flowchart. So we have we set it up,
you have just like, the typical wrong, you need
a, you need to develop for the model. Here,
I have a four pin ready, ready to go. All right.
And, and, and in the beginning, I know nothing
about my solution manifold. So I just picked my
first one randomly. All right, and, and then I saw
a four pin at this one point mu one, okay, now you
have one pin. So you can construct a 211. Network
A is one. So it's a little network 211 with one
one neuron in the middle. And then you'll go,
you'll go train it, you go trace this through our
network everywhere, you sort of use your current
reducer model to explore your space everywhere.
Because every time I include I record my code,
I include my loss, this is residual based loss,
right? And the greedy, the greedy step is that
well, I take a look at all those laws of the whole
parameter domain is that you know, small enough,
of course, when these two are one is likely
it's not. So it's not small enough. So I'm going
to take this one is a greedy idea, the one that
maximizes my my IRAs, he made an error indicator.
And that's why I'm going to someone else writes
is a classical greedy algorithm has quite a bit
of theory behind. So once I determined my mu
two, I go ahead and and call my four pin again
at that mu two. So now I have my second pin.
So my 211 network became a two to one, and then
I repeat this loop, I go from 221231241, and
so forth. And you're hopefully at some point,
this global maximum loss over the parameter
May is less than a tolerance then then we
stop we'll take that as as to VPN networks.
So we tested this thing on three examples,
the burgers and Alan Kahn and Klein Gordon.
So they have respectively 123 parameter values
and this just you know, the setup is interest
time, I'm going to not dive into the details
here. I'm going to show you as a result of of one
equation, so here is a bogus the Bacchus equation
and the first one is well the network's decided to
sample so we started not exactly random, but just
take the middle of the parameter domain and then
you you generate is let the algorithm decide what
to do next, you see it goes to number two, number
three, and they then sort of focus more toward you
know, the lower viscosity and and pick the one
here so in the end, we showed you know this a
lot is last graph as you proceed this process from
one to nine neurons. So here's a very unusual we
only have nine neurons in the hidden layer. And
as the back of here is where is our method. So
we get below two degrees, which is sort of, you
know, in the pin setting, is is about about Okay,
and just to show how powerful this idea of this RB
rom idea is one basically move to the pin setting.
If we do a uniform sampling uniform, so called
a uniform neurons here we just uniformly sampled
the parameter domain and just caught on trains
and put it on to the hidden layer. And it's not
bad. You know, it's worse than the adaptive one,
but not not not Not that bad. This is the more
statistics of the losses, and I'm just showing you
the three year anniversary in three mode. That was
calculated by the GDP. So to test that we tested
on a number of unseen parameter values, but still
within the, the range of the that it was trained.
So it, you know, it does performs reasonably well,
with with, again, the terminal arrows with at the
end of the training. And to show the computational
saving, what I'm showing here is, as the x axis
is a test, case number, so we repeatedly call,
so here the red curve, is if you repeatedly call
your PIN for you know, up to 25 times, and you
you record your record the cumulative running
time, alright. So for the GDP in, you know, you
have a uses initial initial investment, while you
train it, you form your your GDP, and afterwards,
this is the slope is basically flat. The sole
measure was a marginal time, right, so the slope
ratio is more than 100. So you know too much to
all of multidose speed up. But I've got just like
other, you know, wrong approaches, you know,
you use this for Madikeri. So, if you need to
basically need more queries and this intersection
point, right, you need more than that number of,
for this administration, in more than that number
of queries is worthwhile to, to, to invest in the
in the in the learning stage. So for the other
two equations, we got very similar result,
I'm just showing you some nice pictures of the of
the of the other two equations. And as to be that
factor is more than the burgers. And just to
repeat myself, so the island can equation, we
use a self adaptive pin developed by these cards,
colleagues, and we don't need to get into the pin,
just, you know, take it and run it add Well, the
TPP and Agros and ask us to train. And that's
it. So I want to spend perhaps the remaining time,
again to talk about the extension to the nonlinear
reduction setting that what we were calling the
tCpd pins where we bring back the and weeds. So
this for, again, for diffusion type of problem
that was a result that basically shows you know,
there's a low rank structure. So the this, this
and we this decreases exponentially fast. Which
allows us to construct a, a small space to
approximate a sort of manifold, right. But
for transport dominated phenomenon. So here, what
I meant is you sample a long time just above the
same thing, if you sample a long time, there's a
low rank structure here for the transport even if
you sample a long time, you know, it's just like
identity matrix is the same thing moving forward,
you don't really, really get a lot of structure,
if you do SVD to the matrix. And in fact,
it can be proven that this instead of an upper
bound, like the diffusion setting, for transport
dominated situation, there is a lower bound.
So your waves will be not will not decay faster
than that, then there is a fairly slow decay. So
that's the main hurdle for the linear reduction.
And the reason for colleagues who started
working on nonlinear reduction in the last few
years. So we just very briefly what we did is we
incorporated this is not a new idea incorporated
with this transform idea. I'm listening, again, a
partial list of results in the last few years. So
what we did is, is basically we're adding a layer
adding a layer of this transforms the transform
blocks to to to the GDP GDP. And for you see the
you know, each transform for each meal or meal,
I have a transform. And that's it. That's it.
I'm going to show you some results to you know,
to demonstrate how it all works. But the key point
here is that once you have this structure defined,
you give me a new mu m the weights, the C's that
that was that was the GDP in And as transforms,
there was simultaneous trained by this
reduced another walk. And he's still you know,
in the pin setting in the pin fashion meaning the
PD is incorporated as as a loss function. And,
and this is basically a novel nonlinear RB by
incorporating these lists this transform before
putting it into the pins.
And that was, you know, in recently submitted
paper. So, to show you how how it works,
here is a is a result from the Walpole 2017 paper,
this is a function is a pretty nasty function. So,
this is some of the snapshots as you change
the mu value. So, you'll see, first of all,
they all have this continuity, and some of
these communities on the left some of these
communities on the right, and, and moreover, as it
is community moves as you change the mu. Alright,
this is a typical challenges setting for the court
for nonlinear reduction. So here I'm showing you
some result, the grades are exact solution. If we
do a, you know, textbook like ranch interpolation,
you get this is, you know, the, the sawtooth,
right and, and in in model reduction settings,
there's something called an EI M empirical
interpolation method. What it does is either
uses the same family, the same members of the
same family, to interpolate to use them as basis
to I'm going to pick just like RB, I'm going
to pick me one, mu two, mu three and so on,
I generally want you to use reuse those as
the basis as opposed to perhaps, you know,
the normals. And that's, that's, that's a
powerful thing, you can still cannot avoid
the SWAT tools. But if you apply the so called
ctgb Dickin idea, you get basically identical
approximation a perfect approximation. Because his
idea is if it detects an automatic aligned up that
is community, once these discontinuities line up,
then you can do your your linear combination that
will be more effective. And so we apply that to
a few PDS and I'm showing you one result here is
a nonlinear reaction equation. So we are able to
solve the family of equations, the parametric PDE,
you want using one new long, 1 Billion Euro,
right is one year round persons is hoping as
one neuron so that's a nonlinear the tCpd result,
if we were to use law, regional GDP in you know,
you will need need 10 But even waste Han the
the, the the result is worse than the nonlinear
result with one neuron. So to conclude, we have
the first pin accelerator, which is the RPM is
what do we believe is the first female celebrator
that is follows Rome idea that RPM framework that
preserves a pin structure relies on in our last
data and it's now intrusive, sort of, you know,
you you pro existing thing, you can just plug
it to your to your network. The loss is is you
know is guided by the greedy construction and
natural features offline online decomposition.
And we're realizing actual speed up in practice.
And we extended to the to the nonlinear reduction
setting. So, you know, the code is available on
GitHub. And here's my email and I also want to
acknowledge funding support from from SF F Os R
and under the MAS program at a must animals and
we have a pretty active Center for Scientific
Computing data science research. So acknowledge or
you know, appreciate all your support. And thank
you everyone for your attention to the talk today.
Thank you. Thank you so much for the wonderful
talk. A beautiful idea. I especially like the fact
that you combine the video spaces, the framework
and you know with the pins, idea, awesome,
wonderful job. Okay, let's have a q&a sessions.
If you have questions, please unmute yourself and
Ask questions. Maybe I can start you know, the
pins. Beautiful idea. Very popular problem with
the pins, though is the fact that they impose
the boundary condition and initial conditions
in weekly, like in the loss functions, one of the
lowest functions. But I mean, for one key problem,
that's better, okay. But if you go to 2d 3d and
then complex geometry is no longer trivial task
to imposing those boundary condition and initial
condition and your framework. You know, basically
relying on the origin options framework. Right,
right. Yeah. So it, you know, those issues with
the cleanse, no imposing the boundary condition,
initial condition. Your method has that too.
Because we are using relying on the original
cleanse, if you can comment on that. Yeah,
it basically if I raise it, higher rates are
the advantages, but also the disadvantages of
pins. Right. A lot of can, you know, it's up for
debate, I think, you know, to implemented in to
this really, is, is, you know, people certainly
do the right will in terms of accuracy and,
and, and speed compared with traditional methods,
that's a different story is doable, I guess, the I
there is a there is a method called a variational.
Pin, and with which I am not familiar, we know,
either traditional numerical method, sometimes
you don't want to, you don't want to enforce
your boundary conditions in a strong fashion. And
that would change that would have negative impact
on the on the conversion speed, for example,
that gets converted order. So, yeah, there may
be some of those that we you know, we have to
go through the more colloquial more variation
approach for for for to, to overcome some of those
disadvantages, but yeah, you know, the overall
message, are you exactly right. You know, this
entire race, the whole the whole frame, or is,
is a is a pin flavor in the reduced level, so that
you can read pretty much everything from there.
Yeah, yeah. Beautiful idea,
though. Thank you. Is there
any question from audience?
Otherwise, I can keep asking?
Yes, you're on mute yourself. You want to ask?
Yeah, just a quick question. So, in, in Nevada
RBM, you know, like, like, like many other,
you know, frameworks, there is the challenge with,
with dimensionality, right? Meaning, the curse of
dimensionality. And then forgive me this, this
could be a, you know, kind of naive question,
but combining or BM and pain? Um, I'm not saying
you have tried it, I'm not even saying you
have thought about it, but are there ways to, to
benefit from this combination? Right. To alleviate
right, the challenge with curse of dimensionality
and the reason I asked that question is you do
know that there are problems, where we have many,
many parameters. And for example, you do not like
that is, for example, topology optimization,
where you have like, you know, 1000s of, you know,
parameters. And yeah, I mean, it's just, you
know, just thinking out loud, and I yeah,
that's certainly a tough problem. I think
Mueller people have been working on it. I mean,
the in terms of in the vanilla RB. And so the
Manila GDP and let's say, we want to make sure
the Prime Minister May is well covered. So
you are doing, you know, a condition grid,
let's say on the on the primary domain, and
of course, they have an exponential increase
the cardinality Have a lot of your tests of your
training site would exponentially increase with
the number of parameters, the training, offline
training, because every time you're exploring the
domain, so as the training is linear with with
respect to the cardinality of your training set.
Last things we can sort of due to delays, what
overcome but delays the cost of dimensionality,
maybe you want to, you know, we have some result,
I think, including young souls group has some
result in perhaps, you know, some some smarter
way of sampling. Or maybe you introduce maybe
a gradient based approaches, we had some result
a few years back, you know, we can reconstruct,
you know, we we based on a fine sampling present,
with once, with one swing, we can reconstruct a
sort of a more area where you want to explore
keep exploring, and those areas, you know,
use why you don't need to explore again, your
next greedy step, or that is at the most delay the
curse of dimensionality dimensioned. Yeah, yeah.
That's a tough, tough one. Thank you. Thank you.
Related to that, if you can
go to slide 11. Any, okay?
All right. So why don't we not?
waste a lot of slides.
Yeah. Oh, awesome. Okay, yeah, I'm here,
IBM, knees, less number of data, because,
you know, greedy approach, greedy algorithm,
you know, the pod can also apply the greedy
sampling. That way, you can reduce
the amount of the folder model data,
then you can move the pod to
the same category of concern.
Yeah, yeah. I guess by this? I mean, it's a
vanilla version. Yeah. I know for sure. Like
your work on the acid here, right, for
example, is deep plasticity. Last week
elasticity. Lastly, we have
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
The vanilla version. Right. And it's
kind of done. Thank you. Thank you.
All right. Is there any other
questions? So what is the next step,
you're obviously one or, you know, makes the
problem more complex. Like instead of 1d,
you may want to extend it
to 2d and then 3d and etc.
Yeah, that's certainly a very wuzzy direction.
So right now we're focusing on to go towards the
nonlinear direction a bit more. So the right now
we the nonlinear, the TCP IP idea walks, you know,
for like, for transport, I didn't show the
result here. But for transport is in the paper,
for for linear transport, you know, you you
use one new round, you get machine accuracy,
basically, compared with the for the model. For
other things like nonlinear reaction diffusion.
And then, you know, we some convection, you know,
they work out well for burgers. And we're trying
to do all the low equation. So the, for those
ones, the transform blocks are not that easy to,
to handle. So right now, the transform is simply a
fine transform, you have a fine each block of the
transform layer. That's good enough for for a lot
of equations. But for not as a case for, you know,
in viscous before, in this case, the bulk of
the steel good enough for the agreement problem,
for example, or the different remain problems.
And for Euler, that's a challenging, even even for
the underlying theme. So, you know, that's what
we're currently working on now. Yeah, I'm actually
certainly a challenge. Yeah. It's challenging
for him. And it's certainly a challenge for the
the other data driven approach.
data driven approach, right. That's
yeah. Yeah, I have a question. Yeah, sure.
Yeah. Hello, Jana. Nice to see you. And Hi.
And so people found from NPM month book. So
my question is that so you'll use the shifter
to transform the coordinate and time. But it's
different from other work, love for other work,
they also use some kind of construction to
return back to the unsafe kid coordinate
system. So but it seems to me that your shift
the coordinate, and then you're just gonna work
simply in a shift to the coordinate system
and the the the reconstructions that are in
the original coordinate system is missing from
the from your overall network. I don't know.
What's what's the difference from your overall
network? Probably existing network. Yeah. In
terms of in terms of the shipping idea, and
there's a scaling, right, in terms of that,
nothing is new. So we're basically just
incorporated that idea to the team under
the GDP setting. So included that in
the as an additional layer. So yeah,
so at least here are some references.
The certainly, that idea is no new.
Yes. It still from other work? They
they have two steps shifting and
reconstruction. Yeah. But it seems to me you
have shifting and then your work simply in
the shift kid coordinate system. So I don't
know whether whether your your your piece,
the GPT piece already implicitly included
this reconstruction step. Certainly.
Yes. Yes. Yes. I missed that part. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. So you know, we will go back to the first
layer, the input layer, right? It's kind of
like, that's the second step you go back to
the original coordinate. So the whole thing is
not defined from the original input delay or x
t? Because shaved Okay. Evaluation from the whole
thing means that means the reconstruction Yeah.
Okay. Thank you.
Awesome. Is there any other
question from audience?
Well, if not, let's thank our wonderful speaker,
Yanni. Thank you so much, for the
great idea and great talk. We were
able to follow it very easily. You have a
great presentation skill as well. Thank you
so much. Youngstrom. And thank you,
everyone, for for for tuning in today.
I appreciate your attention. All right.
Thank you so much. Take care. Take
care. Yeah, man. Are you still there?
Yeah. Would you mind sharing the slide with
me? Of course. Yeah, I can. Awesome. Yeah,
of course not. I mean, I'll
send to you. It was not. Okay.
Thank you. All right. Keep in touch. Bye. Bye.